foreign
[Music]
okay Magnus is playing okay there we go
let's go that's so frustrating I mean I
was completely winning I was it's been
zero chances and I found the only way to
lose the only way
he plays instantly regardless of the
position and always the tactics always
work out for him always
amazing property of a chessler
anytime there's tactical complications
it works out for him okay I've learned a
piece behind this didn't take it
yeah I get an easier opponent exactly
I mean I think anybody's easier than
Jose this tournament the way he the
speed with which he's inaccuracy that
he's playing is otherworldly I don't
think Magnus is comparable
um
okay
no no oh no
you could have taken okay whatever
I'm gonna win
or am I no it's a draw
wait is this a draw
it is a draw no way it's a draw this is
a theoretical draw I'm gonna lose oh my
God it's a draw watch
Magnus
find the Grand Prix it's annoying
foreign
oh my gosh Andrew are you serious
oh come on into this in a Boulevard
really
okay good job
good job
hope you strato winning this one if he
wins it which is not a given by the way
I mean
I forgot he does this now he never used
to do that now he does it all the time
I should have waited
[Music]
I mean not no no chance after the second
move of the game
[Music]
so many of these moments today
okay 9.67
busted here
gonna win this Pawn at least
now it's impossible
what am I doing garbage play
[Music]
messed up a little bit
but then I messed up in return again now
I gotta flag him
not even close see there's no chance
here
too too slow
come on you can't be that predictable
demon
come on Dima
can't be that predictable
that was a garbage garbage game I I have
no idea how I won that
okay and of course we get Magnus
panic
here okay I gotta win
at least I gotta play for a win now but
why did I do that it should have been a
draw okay I'll make a draw
crap I was winning
we made three draws of Magna so far
okay driving Magnus is not the worst
result in the world so
and Gwen
am I losing
I guess I am
yeah I messed that up I messed up the
line but it's not so clear
um
foreign
[Music]
the winnable game
always Androids tournaments always has
to be Andrew
one okay just resigned
okay
seriously
I don't know what I'm doing
oh he's got this
it's happening here
I'm not an exchange simply because I'm
busted
no Magnus is super freaking good
sometimes
okay once Bishop G6 I guess
foreign
no chance that game I was just I got
shut out
in the meantime penguin gets a bunch of
easy pairings
I have no no doubt about that
come on Karina Karina please resign
thank you Karina
no board Nick's on a 14-game winning
streak who are these people and how did
they do it okay now I'm playing boarding
I gotta stop history
because that would potentially secure
third place for me
or a second if I can
yeah foreign
there
okay I'm gonna try to create some
counter play against this thing
oh he blundered his Queen people under
this queen
blunder this queen oh my gosh oh Sasha's
gotta be upset I mean that that is just
a terrible way to win
and it resigns we got Sasha so we
stopped his shriek
that was a huge win
excellent okay now moving on not that I
like to win games against my friends but
right now we're in action
competitive mode
and a quack quack
[Music]
you see like making the duck sound when
you read his name
the problem now okay why didn't you do
that it was really stupid
um I almost wondered that too
okay just going oh no
what am I doing
I'm gonna win I think but it's gonna be
a close game
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]
no I saw a problem with that move the
moment I played it
I can take take because here maybe
[Music]
jababa London ladies and gentlemen
London system
all right sorry
may I present to you
London system
he sucks at chess but he can win some
games very good yes give me a carry
another throat yes
okay penguin gotta win this one
[Music]
foreign
shits
okay why am I panic panic panic panic
panic
panic panic
okay I'm still behind him but this is a
big one
foreign
[Music]
it doesn't matter it's not there's not
going to be enough time
no no it doesn't matter all right I'm
just gonna stall it out we got second
place by 16 points and Magnus was fifth
he tilted Magnus tilted 100 points away
wow and we got second place let's go
overcoming the bad form initially
with a 16 game streak at the end that
was awesome and I beat Andrew in that
critical game
good start to the day
okay obviously Hikaru was in the
stratosphere very early
hikara was very much in the stratosphere
early but
but um
not bad my score was 70 out of 85.
Hikaru was 69 and a half out of 76. so
the interesting thing is I got more
points than Hikaru but I didn't get as
many streaks so it wasn't it there just
weren't as many points
I got more draws than icaro
I mean one of the problems is that
nobody can seem to ever give Hikaru a
tough game
in bullet in any tournament if they just
collapse but all credits at him of
course
I think people just see Hikaru and they
they know they're going to lose
and that's why he wins so many games
really really really fast
yeah we're gonna head over to the title
Arena I'm gonna play offstream folks um
it's two hours so I really do have to
start
I'm gonna head out
and I'll see you guys later thank you
everybody
uh for supporting me during bullet brawl
I'll be back possibly tonight and I'll
see you guys later second place in
Boulevard we'll take it
foreign
[Music]